hello readers today i want to talk about
vocabulary and how many english words
have greek or latin roots embedded in
them and how you can use that to your
advantage the story of why english has
greek and latin in it at all is super
fascinating to me and if i allowed
myself i'd go off on a big old tangent
about it but let's save that for another
time
suffice it to say that english has latin
and greek chunks in it for
fun history reasons and and let's just
leave it at that for now i'm not going
to say that you need to be able to speak
modern greek or read ancient latin in
order to understand english but many
complicated words are made up of little
language building blocks that we can
break apart using the power of
understanding
that was cool right i'm cool i'm cool
i'm going to introduce some vocabulary
about vocabulary now so brace yourselves
there's this idea of a root word take
the word dent which is latin for tooth
from that root word we can get the
adjective dental which means about teeth
or the noun dentist which means a person
who specializes in teeth or the noun
dentures which are false teeth
that's what a root is now you can also
combine roots to make words the word
foot
is greek for light
the root graph comes from the greek
for writing
you put those together you get
photograph
or writing with light it's kind of
poetic isn't it to this understanding
let us add the idea of an affix
affixes aren't words or roots but they
are word particles that convey meaning
maybe you've heard of prefixes and
suffixes if you have these are both
types of affixes prefixes attach at the
front end of a word whereas suffixes
attach at the back end an example of a
suffix would be logie meaning the study
of or the science of so we can make a
bunch of words with logie like biology
that's supposed to be a little amoeba
cetology the study or the science of
whales
anthropology the study of human beings
cosmology the study of the universe
so if you see a logi it's going to be
some kind of science or specialized area
of study
a good example of a prefix would be the
greek para which means alongside
so a paralegal is someone who works
alongside lawyers a paramedic works
alongside doctors and if your house is
haunted you don't need a normal pest
control expert to get rid of the ghost
you need a paranormal pest control
expert one that is alongside but not
within normalcy and thus you call the
ghostbusters
so what does all of this mean for you as
a reader well when i encounter a word i
don't understand
it's like i had been walking down a
hallway and was suddenly confronted with
a locked door
it's frustrating
but the magic the power of studying
roots prefixes and suffixes is that when
you master a small handful of them
you suddenly become the proud owner of a
ring of keys
doors fling themselves open for you you
can go anywhere you can understand any
concept any piece of vocabulary an army
of locked doors fall off their hinges
all at once when you approach don't
believe me
i'll show you
while excavating the foundation for a
geothermal plant my companion neja found
a fossil
upon closer inspection she realized it
was a pterodactyl wow a lot of big words
in that little paragraph now
watch this
excavating
so
hollowing out
foundation
bottom making
geothermal
earth heat
companion
so this is someone you would eat
bread
with so bread together and who do we eat
bread together with our friends
inspection
looking in
or closer
and
pterodactyl pater means wing
dactyl means finger it is a prehistoric
winged reptile
so
while she was digging in the ground to
prepare the bottom of a plant that gets
electricity from the heat of the earth
my friend neja found a fossil when she
looked at it closely she realized it was
a flying reptile with fingery wings
do you see what i mean about keys
studying roots and affixes gives me the
power to look at those words and crack
them apart
you're not so big now vocabulary word
you have no power over me
studying roots prefixes and suffixes
will give you that same power i promise
you it is awesome like literally it
fills me with a sense of awe
the power is yours for the taking
you can learn anything
dave it out
okay we're doing those fun history
reasons though okay the short version is
that first the romans then some vikings
then some french vikings invaded the
island of great britain a bunch of times
over the last 1500 years shaping the
language and making what i like to call
french-shaped dense in the germanic
structure of english
english is a germanic language french is
a romance language meaning not that it
is full of love but that it is an
offshoot of latin or you know roman
french took root in 11th century english
and merged with it grafting an enormous
amount of greek and latin vocabulary
onto a german root stock
we often reach for latin and greek
compounds when we compose new words
which is why we say television in
english which comes from the greek tele
meaning far away and the latin vire
meaning to see
if we reached for germanic roots to make
new words we'd call a television a
farseer because indeed that's what the
word is in german
ferenzan so why do we have greek and
latin in our vocabulary because england
was colonized by french speakers almost
a thousand years ago imagine what
english will sound like in another
thousand years anyway thanks for coming
on this tangent with me david out for
real this time bye